In questo capitolo forniremo il framework
per ragionare sugli ambienti di calcolo
che può essere applicato sia al tuo laptop
che scalato fino ai supercomputer
alla fine di questo capitolo
capirai il concetto fondamentale delle risorse di calcolo
e come si relazionano tra loro
quindi cosa sono le risorse di calcolo, in parole semplici
sono i componenti che costituiscono un sistema informatico
avremo la CPU, o unità centrale di elaborazione
che esegue la maggior parte delle istruzioni, avremo la memoria
o RAM, che contiene temporaneamente i dati
e le istruzioni del programma
e abbiamo le GPU, o unità di elaborazione grafica
progettate per il rendering grafico
ma utilizzabili anche per attività di elaborazione generale
che richiedono molta elaborazione parallela
come simulazioni scientifiche, analisi dati o machine learning
queste risorse lavorano insieme per eseguire i programmi
e ciascuna ha la propria unità di misura
ad esempio le unità CPU si misurano in core
e velocità di clock, mentre la memoria si misura in byte
in giga, mega e terabyte
per ciascuno dei nostri problemi
avremo bisogno di un insieme di risorse
per eseguirli
è fondamentale considerare le risorse necessarie per eseguirli
in modo efficiente: il luogo in cui vengono eseguiti i componenti del programma
e la larghezza di banda dell'infrastruttura che li connette
giocano un ruolo significativo
nel determinare le prestazioni complessive
ad esempio una GPU potrebbe essere più veloce per calcolare parti specifiche
del nostro programma, ma se caricare il programma nella memoria della GPU
richiede più tempo di quanto si risparmia
potrebbe essere più veloce usare la CPU al suo posto
ora parliamo dello scaling delle risorse classiche
abbiamo due approcci: scaling verticale
e scaling orizzontale. Lo scaling verticale consiste nell'aument
are la potenza di una singola risorsa
come usare una CPU più potente o aggiungere più memoria
all'interno di un singolo nodo fisico
dove il nodo è un'unità di un cluster di calcolo che racchiude più
risorse al suo interno. Lo scaling orizzontale
consiste nell'aggiungere più risorse
come più CPU o GPU
che lavorano insieme su un singolo nodo o più nodi
entrambi gli approcci hanno i loro vantaggi
e svantaggi, e la scelta dipende dal caso d'uso specifico
e dai requisiti. Introduciamo ora un nuovo tipo di risorsa:
le risorse quantistiche. Le risorse quantistiche elaborano informazioni quantistiche
con un'unità di elaborazione quantistica, o QPU. Una QPU
è l'intero sistema responsabile
di accettare un insieme di istruzioni quantistiche eseguibili
o un quantum circuit e restituire
una risposta accurata. Questo significa
che la QPU include uno o più chip quantistici
come ad esempio un sistema IBM Quantum
oltre a numerosi componenti aggiuntivi
in un refrigeratore a diluizione
che raffredda il chip quantistico
come amplificatori quantistici, elettronica di controllo
e il computer classico necessario
per attività come il mantenimento delle istruzioni
e delle forme d'onda in memoria, l'accumulo dei risultati
e la futura decodifica per la correzione degli errori
in generale le risorse quantistiche si misurano
in termini di qualità: la scala di fedeltà a strati
il numero di qubit
e la velocità: le operazioni per layer di circuit al
secondo, o CLOPS. Oggi tratteremo il chip quantistico
come unità di misura, in modo simile a come i sistemi di gestione delle risorse
trattano le GPU: non per numero di core
ma per unità intere. E lo scaling?
Come per le risorse classiche, lo scaling delle risorse quantistiche può
essere categorizzato in verticale
e orizzontale. Lo scaling verticale
consisterebbe nell'aumentare il numero di qubit per chiplet
o per chip
lo scaling orizzontale consisterebbe nel collegare chip
con accoppiatori o con interconnessioni classiche
con questa definizione di base
parliamo ora della gestione delle risorse
la gestione delle risorse nell'infrastruttura di calcolo si riferisce
al processo di pianificazione
allocazione e controllo dell'uso delle risorse computazionali
come CPU, memoria, storage
e larghezza di banda di rete per garantire un utilizzo
efficiente ed efficace delle risorse
puoi immaginare la gestione delle risorse
come un gioco di Tetris multidimensionale in cui i blocchi
rappresentano i requisiti del tuo job
e ogni dimensione è un'unità di risorsa. Il compito generale
è far entrare questi blocchi-job in un cubo
che rappresenta tutte le tue risorse disponibili. La gestione delle risorse
è un compito molto complesso e i diversi centri di calcolo implementano
strategie diverse per configurare la propria infrastruttura
in base alle esigenze specifiche della propria utenza
per applicare i concetti che abbiamo appena imparato useremo
Slurm. Slurm è un software open source
per la gestione delle risorse
a scopo dimostrativo
ho una configurazione locale con tre nodi virtuali
possiamo ottenere informazioni su quei nodi di calcolo
eseguendo il comando scontrol
avremo due partizioni, o gruppi di nodi:
normal e quantum. La partizione normal è composta da nodi
che hanno accesso solo a risorse classiche
e la partizione quantum ha accesso alle risorse quantistiche
iniziamo con il semplice
esempio classico hello world con Slurm
per prima cosa abbiamo bisogno del programma hello world in sé.
Eccolo qui, il nostro programma che stampa semplicemente hello
world.
Ora dobbiamo dire al gestore delle risorse
di quali risorse abbiamo bisogno per eseguire questo programma
come abbiamo discusso, Slurm fornisce un modo per specificare
tutti i metadati per un job tramite
uno script di shell
con alcune annotazioni specifiche di Slurm
queste annotazioni ti permettono di specificare i requisiti delle risorse
i parametri di scheduling e altro ancora.
Possiamo controllare il nostro script di submission
e qui troviamo la specifica della partizione
quanti nodi servono, quanti task per nodo verranno
eseguiti, quante CPU per task useremo
e quale script verrà eseguito
e questo è il nostro programma hello world.
Per inviare il nostro job all'esecuzione dobbiamo solo eseguire
un comando, che è sbatch
e fornire il nostro script come argomento
possiamo controllare la coda di esecuzione
e vedere che il nostro programma hello world è in esecuzione
sulla partizione normal sul nodo c1
una volta completato il job possiamo controllare i risultati
guardando il file di output.
E questo è tutto.
Siamo anche interessati a usare risorse quantistiche
quindi creiamo un semplice programma hello world con Qiskit.
Ecco il nostro programma Qiskit, che contiene tutti i
passi necessari di creazione del circuit
ottimizzazione, esecuzione ed elaborazione dei risultati.
E qui tutti i concetti di programmazione di cui abbiamo parlato:
quantum circuit, transpiler
e le primitive di Qiskit
ora dobbiamo creare lo script di submission
come prima, ma qui specifichiamo
i requisiti delle risorse quantistiche
una volta specificate le risorse
e la partizione nel cluster
le risorse quantistiche disponibili
le primitive di Qiskit utilizzeranno
le risorse allocate per eseguire i calcoli quantistici.
Ora dobbiamo eseguire il nostro programma.
E una volta completato il job possiamo controllare i risultati.
Ed ecco il nostro valore di aspettazione.
E questo è tutto per la gestione delle risorse
nella prossima sezione parleremo
dei modelli di programmazione